[Musik]
ab heute gilt die polizei meldet kaum
verstöße gegen die neuen nächtlichen
ausgangs beschränkungen
unterdessen erwägt die politik
lockerungen für geimpfte ein reisestopp
aus indien aus sorge vor der dort
wütenden mutation stuft die
bundesregierung das land als
virusvarianten gebiet ein und abschied
von milva
[Musik]
egal
mit liedern über liebe und freiheit
eroberte sie das deutsche publikum jetzt
ist die italienische sängerin gestorben
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers das ist der
nachrichten samstag für sie geben sie
uns 20 minuten dafür sport nachher in
der sendung mit katja stresow genannt
seit der vergangenen nacht gilt die
sogenannte bundes notbremse einheitlich
und in ganz deutschland das heißt unter
anderem nächtliche ausgangsbedingungen
und zwar zum ersten mal in großen teilen
dieses landes schauen wir uns nochmal
den mechanismus genauer an
wenn die inzidenz an drei
aufeinanderfolgenden tagen über 100
liegt dann greift diese notbremse ab dem
übernächsten tag gelten dann
ausgangssperren und verschärfte kontakt
beschränkungen
sobald die 100 an fünf werktagen am
stück wieder unterbrochen ist enden
diese zusatz regeln und zwar ab dem
übernächsten tag wie sich all das
aktuell in deutschland zeigt damit
beginnen wir heute abend axel konrad hat
den bericht zu dieser uhrzeit dürfen sie
sich eigentlich nicht mehr draußen
aufhalten ohne triftigen grund
delmenhorst in niedersachsen es ist nach
zwölf bundes notbremse ausgangssperre
die inzidenz liegt bei fast 200 die
polizei kontrolliert hier ist alles gut
der kurierfahrer hat eine bescheinigung
vom arbeitgeber
in saarbrücken ticken die uhren offenbar
ein bisschen anders lebenslust stadt
corona frust die inzidenz bei 163 aber
die menschen in der korona modellregion
können sich offenbar nur schwer von den
freiheiten der vergangenen wochen
verabschieden
es ist kurz vor mitternacht und die
party soll noch lange weitergehen
[Musik]
möglich die bundes notbremse verschont
nur die wenigen regionen mit einer
inzidenz unter 100 über 100 greifen dann
unter anderem die ausgangs
beschränkungen ab 150 click and collect
shoppen wie hier in köln nach termin
darf die ware im geschäft nur noch
abgeholt werden
allerdings finde ich dass prinzipiell ja
schon mal ein vorteil dass man jetzt
feste grenzen hat also im prinzip guckt
man auf die inzidenz ihn und weiß was in
deiner stadt geht von allen maßnahmen
ist die ausgangssperre besonders
umstritten vor allem bei den jüngeren
ehrlich gesagt denke ich dass die
menschen sich trotzdem treffen dann
vielleicht sogar noch bei freunden
übernachten und dadurch dir das risiko
sogar noch größer wird als geringer und
dann gibt es noch das land der
glückseligen so nennen sie sich hier in
schleswig holstein selbst an der kieler
förde geht zwar nicht alles aber shoppen
und café besuch im freien sind möglich
dank einer inzidenz deutlich unter 100
die regeln sind nun weitestgehend
einheitlich in deutschland sehr
unterschiedlich aber sind die
möglichkeiten schon länger läuft ja die
diskussion ob und wie die beschränkungen
für geimpfte und genesene überhaupt noch
gelten sollten
bei der nächsten konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten übermorgen könnte es
konkret werden ein entsprechender
regierungsentwurf ist bereits im umlauf
und der sieht so aus unter anderem
angedacht keine testpflicht mehr für
geimpfte und genesene beim friseur oder
beim einkaufen mehr freiheiten könnte es
auch bei kontakt und bei ausgangs
beschränkungen geben ebenso beim reisen
das heißt konkret keine quarantäne
pflicht mehr nicht gerüttelt wird an den
grundlegenden regeln maske tragen und
abstand halten gilt weiter für
alle bringen wir schon kontrolle
banerjee mit dazu in berlin am tag unter
das thema drängt ja sonst werden zum
beispiel von privatunternehmen fakten
geschaffen der zwischenzeit wird das
denn einer ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
am montag mit viel streit oder ist da
tatsächlich konsens absehbar als ich
würde mindestens zwei vorbehalte an die
ganze sache dran heften
denn zum einen ist das ganze nur ein
entwurf und zwar zu einer der
schwierigsten fragen die in dieser
pandemie zu beantworten sind das wird
lange diskussionen nach sich ziehen mit
bundesrat und bundestag die beide noch
zustimmen müssen und zum anderen sollte
man vielleicht die hoffnung auf die
große freiheit die daraus folgen kämpft
könnte für geimpfte und genießen ein
wenig dämpfen denn sie ist mit einem
aber verbunden
weder die impfung auch die vollständige
nicht noch die das durchmachen der kurve
19 erkrankung schützen ja nach jetzigem
kenntnisstand dauerhaft vor einer
ansteckung und deswegen kann eigentlich
auch die wiederherstellung der
grundrechte für geimpfte und genesene
auch nicht automatisch dauerhaft
erfolgen sondern wird vermutlich erst
einmal vorübergehend gewährt werden und
könnte dann zum beispiel durch eine
auffrischung folge impfung wieder
erlangt werden also dass das gebet das
bietet noch sehr viel stoff für
diskussionen
trotzdem werden sich bund und länder
wenn nicht am montag dann sicherlich
irgendwann in nächster zeit schon in
richtung eines solchen entwurfes und
eines solchen modells bewegen denn eines
ist auch klar
verfassungsrechtlich sieht es
tatsächlich so aus dass man die
einschränkung der grundrechte nicht
dauerhaft aufrechterhalten kann
wenn die betroffenen um die es da geht
keine ansteckungsgefahr mehr darstellen
und damit auch nicht mehr zu einer
ausbreitung der pandemie beitragen
erläuterungen aus berlin herzlichen dank
und dazu noch dieser service online in
der zdf- heute- app gibt es alle
eckpunkte was da für geimpfte und
genesene diskutiert wird noch einmal zum
nachlesen
und dann schauen wir jetzt in der
sendung auf die aktuellen offiziellen
corona zahlen die gesundheitsämter
meldeten dem robert-koch-institut 23
1392 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 412 weniger als am sand
tag vor einer woche 286 todesfälle kamen
dazu die sieben tage incidents steigt
leicht auf 164,4 in indien ist die lage
verheerend anders kann man das nicht
beschreiben in den großen städten sind
viele krankenhäuser kollabiert groner
infizierte mit atemnot müssen um
sauerstoff geradezu betteln immer
häufiger ohne erfolg die menschen
sterben buchstäblich vor der tür der
notaufnahme verantwortlich für die
rasante verbreitung ist eine mutation
des virus weshalb deutschland indien ab
montag als sogenanntes virusvarianten
gebiet einordnet das soll den
reiseverkehr einschränken anselm stern
hat die details polizeischutz für einen
sauerstofftransport indiens kampf gegen
korona immer mehr menschen kämpfen ums
überleben immer mehr schwer kranke
müssen behandelt werden immer wieder
fehlt es an sauerstoff für die beatmung
fehlen die betten für die virus
patienten eine solche situation gab es
noch nie sagt dieser arzt alle
intensivbetten in delhi sind belegt
verzweifelt rüttelt diese frau an ihrem
bruder er verliert das bewusstsein
es kommt keine hilfe wenige minuten
später ist er tot berichteten die
augenzeugen
indien meldet immer neue höchststände
auch bei den neuinfektionen ein grund
wohl die mutante b 16 17 deutschland
erklärt indien deshalb zum
virusvarianten gebiet ab montag nur gilt
quasi ein einreiseverbot nur deutsche
und ausländer die dauerhaft hier leben
werden noch ins land gelassen pflicht
ein negativer test und 14 tage
quarantäne
eine regel für deutschland was aber kann
die helfen wenn andere länder europas
anders handeln
es macht überhaupt keinen sinn etwas wie
beispielsweise frankfurt oder dem klub
auch in münchen sperren aber
gleichzeitig über wien oder über paris
in den schengen raum weiter ein weise
stattfindet deswegen brauchen wir
umgehen die koordinierung der
europäischen innenminister bei den
momente die wir in südamerika und
südafrika hat europa viel zu spät
reagiert fest steht die lage in indien
wird immer schlimmer
das system überlastet patienten für die
keinen sauerstoff kein arzt kein
krankenhaus platz mehr da ist
deutschen die in indien leben und nicht
gegen korona geimpft sind rät das
auswärtige amt nun sie sollten das land
verlassen
wie die korea krise bewältigt werden
kann das ist das thema das die menschen
aktuell am meisten beschäftigt auch in
sachsen anhalt wo in sechs wochen ein
neuer landtag gewählt wird
1,8 millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
sind wahlberechtigt können also darüber
entscheiden ob es bei der cdu geführten
landesregierung bleiben soll
bald geht es mit der briefwahl los
sommerspecial schildert uns jetzt die
ausgangslage reiner haseloff will zum
dritten mal ministerpräsident werden für
ihn und seine cdu kein leichter weg
masken affäre und k fragen streit
drücken auf die stimmung
im fokus stehen auch weiterhin die
korona krise und ihre wirtschaftlichen
folgen
alle sind ja eigentlich betroffenen
entweder sind bestimmte branchen gar
nicht mehr im geschäft oder menschen
sind in kurzarbeit oder können eben
bestimmte dienstleistung nicht in
anspruch nehmen
in jüngsten umfragen hat die cdu leicht
verloren ebenso wie ihr größter
herausforderer die afg 2016 mit gut 24
prozent in den landtag eingezogen hält
sie als einzige partei wahlkampf
kundgebungen ab und nimmt dort mit
parlamentarier volksverräter ihre themen
corona familien und asylpolitik dass die
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
wählerstimmen kosten könnte
fürchten sie nicht hier im osten wir
sind mit der staatssicherheit große
warum da hatte niemand angst vom
verfassungsschutz
heute vor fünf jahren sind die grünen
mit cdu und spd die erste kenia
koalition eingegangen als bollwerk gegen
rechts sie setzen weiter vor allem auf
den klimaschutz
das ist die große aufgabe für die welt
für deutschland und für sachsen anhalt
und wir sehen dass es immer mehr
menschen gibt die das als ein wirkliches
zukunftsthema begreifen
zurzeit profitieren die grünen
anscheinend vom bundestrend 2016 nur
knapp ins parlament gerutscht könnten
sie nun sogar zweistellig werden
leichtem aufwind auch die spd ihre
spitzenkandidatin wirbt mit
krankenhausinvestitionen und höheren
löhnen und gibt sich mit blick auf den
koalitionspartner angriffslustig und für
den bereich schule wissen wir dass wir
von der cdu dort einen bildungsminister
haben der es nicht kann wir haben ideen
und können diese auch umsetzen
mit ähnlichen themen ist eva von angern
für die linke am start corona bedingt
kann sie nur noch selten ins gespräch
kommen und nimmt viel frust mit die
menschen haben jetzt 15 monate in
isolation gelebt sie wollen reden sie
wollen ihre probleme benennt land wissen
und vor allem wollen die menschen
lösungen die anzubieten bleibt den
parteien nur noch wenig zeit ins ausland
seit fast drei monaten versinkt mehr und
mehr im chaos
am ersten februar übernahm das militär
dort die macht mit dem putsch kam die
gewalt friedliche massenproteste wurden
brutal zerschlagen demonstranten getötet
der widerstand gegen die generelle aber
bleibt wie das blutvergießen in mir
einmal beendet werden kann darüber
berieten heute die ostasiatischen
staaten bei einem sondergipfel normen
odenthal nach vier stunden flug setzt
die maschine der myanmar airways sicher
in jakarta auf der mann der dann die
gangway hinab schreitet ist in einer
anderen welt gelandet general mit online
trägt heute anzug kommt in zivil seine
einladung zum gipfel des
südostasiatischen staatenbundes asien
ist eine heikle sache
sie hebt den diktator den putschisten
auf politische augenhöhe
die entscheidung der asian führer sich
persönlich zu treffen spiegelt die große
sorge über die situation in myanmar
wieder das bündnis ist entschlossen
myanmar aus dieser krise heraus zu
helfen
die frage ist geht das nur mit den mann
der an der spitze der militär untersteht
der mann der die demokratie ausgehebelt
der die befehle gab und gibt der für
brutalste gewalt auf den straßen ihren
maß verantwortlich ist hunderte tote
inzwischen und kein ende in sicht genau
das aber fordern die asian chefs heute
die lage sei untragbar sagte indonesiens
präsident das töten müsse sofort
aufhören politische gefangene sofort
freikommen
in online habe sich zugänglich gezeigt
heißt es offen für vermittlung und
wirtschaftliche hilfe auf die myanmar
angewiesen ist mehr denn je sagt der
general den befehl zum putsch gegeben
hat die asian führer sind auf einem
schmalen grat unterwegs zwischen druck
und dialog sie verurteilen deutlich was
in myanmar geschieht und setzten sich
zugleich mit dem verantwortlichen an
einem tisch an ergebnis wird man sie
messen und das muss ein ende der gewalt
sein sagt unser korrespondenten normen
odenthal in indonesien wird seit
mittwoch ein u-boot vermisst wir haben
darüber berichtet heute haben
suchmannschaften vor der küste von bali
teile des u-boots gefunden auch aus dem
inneren
die marine geht davon aus dass das boot
gesunken ist damit gibt es praktisch
keine hoffnung mehr überlebende zu
finden
an bord waren 53 seeleute zu den
gefundenen teilen gehören eine torpedo
hülle und eine flasche mit schmierstoff
gegenstände also die ohne schweren
schaden nicht nach außen gelangt werden
das wrack liegt in 850 metern tiefe
zugelassen ist das boot nur für 500
meter der 24 april 1915 markiert den
beginn der massaker an den armeniern im
osmanischen reich
das war ein völkermord sagt jetzt auch
us präsident joe biden und übernimmt
damit offiziell die wortwahl anderer
länder wie deutschland vor allem in
armenien selbst wurde heute der knapp
1,5 millionen opfer gedacht tausende
menschen pilgerten zur gedenkstätte und
legten blumen nieder
die türkei kritisierte die neue
einschätzung der usa dafür gebe es keine
legale basis und jetzt in der sendung
ein abschied will war ist tot
la rosa wie die italiener ihre landsfrau
nannten wegen ihrer langen roten haare
sie interpretierte chansons und brecht
sang schlager immer engagiert und mit
viel gefühl will war wurde 81 jahre alt
der nachruf jetzt von annette hilsenbeck
es waren lieder über leidenschaft und
liebe mit dem müll war die herzen der
deutschen in den 1970 er jahren ansprach
deren sehnsucht nach italien
und das alles auf deutsch die sogar
deutsche haltung zeigt eine echte diva
die als maria ilva burkhard i in einem
fischerdorf in norditalien geboren
worden war als tochter einer schneiderin
und eines händlers ich habe gedacht dass
mein leben in meinem geburtsort boro
spielen würde und dass ich dort eine
schneiderin entdeckt wird sie 1961 beim
schlagerfestival in san remo den gewinnt
sie zwar nicht erobert aber fortan
italien im sturm und macht den 70er
jahren international karriere und in
deutschland lieben sie die fans
neben schlagern sind sie auch politische
chansons in italien nannte man sie la
rossa die rote wegen ihrer haarpracht
und wegen ihres politischen engagement
[Musik]
in mailand spiel ziehen bertolt brechts
dreigroschenoper und mit dessen die dann
durch ganz europa erhält dafür gar das
bundesverdienstkreuz
im jahr 2010 der rücktritt von der bühne
aus gesundheitlichen gründen
ich glaube dass ich meine arbeit gut und
mit würde getan habe nun ist mir war in
mailand gestorben was bleibt ist die
erinnerung haben eine große künstlerin
und ihre lieder
katja hat einige dieser lieder auf lager
aber sie präsentiert jetzt doch lieber
den sport ist glaube ich besser für alle
und die meldungen des tages aus der
fußball bundesliga lautet die bayern
sind heute noch nicht vorzeitig
deutscher meister denn die münchner
verloren bei mainz 05 mit 1 zu 2 das
sind die ergebnisse des 31
spieltags mainz bayern also zwei zu eins
der bvb gewinnt in wolfsburg zwei zu
null freiburg hoffenheim eins zu eins
union berlin schlägt bremen drei zu eins
das abendspiel leverkusen frankfurt mit
exklusiven free tv bildern im aktuellen
sportstudio und bereits gestern augsburg
augsburg köln 2 zu 3 die bayern also
heute noch nicht meister vielleicht aber
morgen sollte leipzig nicht gegen
stuttgart gewinnen dahinter wolfsburg
frankfurt dortmund und auch noch
leverkusen mit chancen auf einen
champions-league-platz in der zweiten
hälfte schauen wir nach unten bremen
nach der siebten niederlage in serie im
sturzflug richtung abstieg bielefeld
spielt morgen härter durch die
quarantäne noch mit nachholspielen
schalke bereits abgestiegen
im aktuellen sportstudio hat katrin
müller-hohenstein zwei interessante
gäste im gespräch peter fischer
präsident von eintracht frankfurt und
mit philipp lahm spricht sie über die
kommende em und auch über die bayern
natürlich 23 uhr geht es los zum turnen
elisabeth seitz galt bei der em in basel
in der schweiz als titelkandidaten am
stufenbarren doch statt gold gab es für
die 27 jährige den absturz und die große
enttäuschung
elisabeth seitz einen tag nach platz
fünf im mehrkampf ist der traum eine
medaille am stufenbarren zu gewinnen
nach nur 14 sekunden beendet nach einem
unsauberen jäger an ihrem lieblingsgerät
kann sie die stange nicht mehr fassen
und stürzt ab bleibt dabei unverletzt am
ende platz sieben den em titel holt sich
in einer absolut fehlerfreien leistung
in allen teilsegmenten mit
schwierigkeitsgraden
die russin die volleyballerinnen des
dresdner sc haben zum sechs mal die
deutsche meisterschaft gewonnen im
entscheidenden fünften spiel der
finalserie schlugen sie den mtv
stuttgart souverän in drei sätzen
die dresdnerinnen hier
diagonalangreiferin maja stock mit einem
ass zur 1 0 satzführung lagen nach den
ersten beiden spielen gegen stuttgart
schon mit 0 2 zurück ehe sie sich doch
noch in dieses entscheidungsspiel retten
konnten
heute aber es zeigt sich das team von
trainer babbel von beginn an stärker und
kann mit außenangreiferin jennifer
jannis k schon im dritten durchgang zum
matchgewinn aufschlagen
ein starker dresdner block beendet das
finale 20 21 und sorgt für den
vielumjubelten sechste meistertitel der
briesker olivers bauen
und der trainer hat verraten wird soll
auch ein bisschen gefeiert werden in der
blase vielleicht ja mit liedern von may
war vielleicht vielen dank katja viel
sonnenschein verspricht erst und ali
gleich nach uns hier und dann empfehle
ich ihnen das heute journal natürlich
mit der kollegin marietta slomka um 22
uhr 45
auch morgen am sonntag sind wir hier
gerne für sie da
bis dann aber erst ihnen allen einen
sehr angenehmen samstagabend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter warme luft gibt es
durchaus über europa aber hauptsächlich
im westen und die erreicht uns nicht
denn dieses umfangreiche hoch das blog
die wärme quasi im gegenteil bei uns
kommt eher kühlere luft an als im
südwesten europas schauen wir in die
nacht gibt es wieder im norden mehr
bewölkung als im süden klart es auf und
die temperaturen sinken auf minus zwei
grad im vogtland und 5 grad am oberrhein
fünf grad sind es auch an der nordsee
das wäre die temperaturspanne morgen
wieder im norden mehr wollten als im
süden arbeit die lassen auch mal die
sonne durch ansonsten ziehen im osten
einzelne schauer durch das wird aber
nicht viel sein es ist viel zu trocken
derzeit im süden gibt es verbreitet viel
sonnenschein und das bei höchsten
temperaturen dort bis 20 grad im
südwesten
sonst liegen wir bei neun bis zwölf grad
und 8 grad an der ostsee die nächsten
tage
am montag ist es noch trocken komplett
war 9 bis 18 grad am dienstag bekommen
wir im süden etwas regen dazu sonst aber
weiterhin trocken und auch am mittwoch
gibt es im süden schauer die
temperaturen dann nur noch bei 18 grad
ein schöner abend